[Music]
stretched across a tree peppered expanse
in southern africa
lies the magnificent ruins of great
zimbabwe
a medieval stone city of astounding
wealth and prestige
located in the present-day country of
zimbabwe it's the site of the largest
known settlement ruins in sub-saharan
africa
second on the continent only to the
pyramids of egypt
but the history of this city is shrouded
in controversy
defined by decades of dispute about who
built it
and why its name comes from the shona
word
mad zimbabwe meaning big house of stone
for its unscalable stone walls that
reach heights of nearly 10 meters
and run for a length of about 250 meters
for its grandeur and historical
significance it was named a unesco world
heritage site in 1986
back in the 14th and 15th centuries it
was a thriving city
spread across nearly eight square
kilometers great zimbabwe was defined by
three main areas
the hill complex where the king lived
the great enclosure
reserved for members of the royal family
and the valley complex where regular
citizens lived
rulers were both powerful economic and
religious leaders for the region
at its highest point the city had a
bustling urban population of 18 000
people
and was one of the major african trade
centers at the time
what enabled this growth was great
zimbabwe's influential role
in an intercontinental trade network
connected to several key city-states
along the east african swahili coast
it was part of the larger indian ocean
trade routes
the city generated its riches by
controlling the sources and trade of the
most
prized items gold ivory
and copper with this mercantile power it
was able to extend its sphere of
influence across
continents fostering a strong arab and
indian trader presence
throughout its zenith archaeologists
have since pieced together the details
of this history
through artifacts discovered on site
there were pottery shards and glassworks
from asia
as well as coins minted in the coastal
trading city of kielwa kisiwani
over 1500 miles away they also found
soapstone bird figures
which are thought to represent each of
the city's rulers
and young calf bones only unearthed near
the royal residence
show how the diet of the elite differed
from the general population
these clues have also led to theories
about the city's decline
by the mid-15th century the buildings at
great zimbabwe were almost all that
remained
archaeological evidence points to
overcrowding and sanitation issues as
the cause
compounded by soil depletion triggered
by overuse
eventually as crops withered and
conditions in the city worsened
the population of great zimbabwe is
thought to have dispersed and formed the
nearby mutapa and tua
states centuries later a new phase of
great zimbabwe's influence began to play
out in the political realm
as people debated who had built the
famous city of stone
during the european colonization of
africa racist colonial officials claimed
the ruins couldn't be of african origin
so without a detailed written record on
hand they instead relied on myths to
explain the magnificence of great
zimbabwe
some claimed it proved the bible story
of the queen of sheba who lived in a
city of riches
others argued it was built by the
ancient greeks
then in the early 20th century after
extensive excavation at the site
the archaeologist david randall mcivor
presented clear evidence that great
zimbabwe was built by indigenous peoples
yet at the time the country's white
minority colonial government
sought to discredit this theory because
it challenged the legitimacy of their
rule
in fact the government actively
encouraged historians to produce
accounts that disputed the city's
african origins
over time however an overwhelming body
of evidence mounted
identifying great zimbabwe as an african
city built by africans
during the 1960s and 70s great zimbabwe
became an important symbol for the
african nationalist movement that was
spreading across the continent
today the ruins at great zimbabwe
alluded to on the zimbabwean flag by a
soapstone bird still stand as a source
of national pride and cultural value
you